une autre urgence québécoise qui déborde
beaucoup de monde
il y a beaucoup de personnes âgées
aussi une vingtaine d'urgences de la
province dépassent le seuil des 150%. du
jamais vu à cette période de l'année
traiter et recevoir des soins aux
urgences devient de plus en plus risqués
on est rendu à une situation partout au
Québec ou
il y a vraiment un danger pour pour
la population il y a une personne sur
deux qui en ce moment vos urgences qui
auraient pu aller ailleurs environ 5000
personnes par jour qu'il faut envoyer
ailleurs qu'à l'urgence Québec présente
trois mesures pour y arriver c'est qu'en
code doute quand vous savez pourquoi
faire le 8 à 1 ça devient la place le 81
devient la ligne de référence pour
orienter les Québécois vers le bon
service Québec crée aussi deux cliniques
d'infirmières praticienne spécialisées à
Montréal dans bien des cas
l'IPS peut prendre en charge
complètement la personne et simplement
référé au médecin quand il y a des
épisodes aigus finalement on veut sortir
des hôpitaux les patients qui n'ont plus
besoin d'y être Québec a trouvé daily à
l'extérieur des hôpitaux pour y arriver
plus de 1600 places à laquelle on est en
appel d'offres il faut soulager les
établissements des patients qui occupent
des liens qui sont en attente d'une
autre source donc ça c'était la mesure
fort la mesure principale et c'était la
cause de de la congestion de
l'engorgement soulagement pour les
médecins qui réclamaient cette mesure
depuis des semaines mais le succès de
ces mesures repose sur un élément
incontournable celui d'avoir
suffisamment de main d'oeuvre ce qui est
loin d'être certain dans le contexte
actuel ici David Gentile Radio-Canada
Montréal